this is a big one
hey
how's it going everybody
mike and mary back for some more
resident knievel we're on to four
one of the
best games ever according to a lot of
people we actually played an hour of
this game for knievel i can't lie put it
on youtube for what like three hours and
there was no audio
there was a bunk problem with the audio
so what i'm gonna do
is remind mary of all the time she
screwed up
when we originally played yes yeah just
so the audience can we'll all enjoy this
bullying her for
oh we'll get into it uh soon but yeah we
can jump right in new game first of the
more action oriented
evil this is the most
famous i think of the
of the resident evil series is the one
that got like the most
praise and acclaim yeah i would agree
i'll never forget it
it was the year when those grisly
murders occurred in the arklay mountains
soon after the news was out to the whole
world revealing that it was the fault of
a secret viral experiment conducted by
the international pharmaceutical
enterprise umbrella i hate those guys
the virus broke out in a nearby mountain
community raccoon city
and hit the peaceful little town
with a devastating blow crippling its
very fast footage from three right there
not taking any chances the president of
the united states ordered a contingency
plan to sterilize raccoon city which is
another word for new whole affair gone
public
the united states government issued an
indefinite suspension of business decree
to umbrella
soon its stock prices crashed and for
all intents and purposes
umbrella
was finished
but then the dude who decided to nuke
raccoon his last name is simmons
find out more about him later
mr simmons president evil's story is
kind of a it's his own
horrendous incident
leon
i received special training via a secret
organization working under the direct
control of the president
i was to assume the responsibility of
protecting the new president's family
why am i the one who always gets the
short end of the stake yo
who are you really
come on and tell us
you are a long way from home cowboy
you have my sympathies guess that's a
local's way of breaking the ice
anyway you know what this is all about
my assignment is to search for the
president's missing daughter what
all by yourself
i'm sure you boys didn't just tag along
so we could sing kumbaya together at
some boy scout bonfire
then again maybe you did
got him dude's got some good comebacks
crazy american it's a direct order from
the chief himself
i tell you it's no picnic
i'm counting on you guys
just promise me that you'll never die
or get burned alive
at the stake or thrown into a lake
what's the last time you played this
game
before the incident was to take on my
duties
daughter when she was abducted when i
was in high school oh really okay that's
the ultimate reason i'm in this
loneliness
yesterday according to our intelligence
there's reliable information about a
sighting of a girl that looks very
similar to the president's daughter
apparently she's being withheld by some
unidentified group of people
who would have thought that my first job
would have been a rescuer
hell yeah this is spain [__]
it's freezing
so cold all of a sudden
must be my imagination it was nothing
sorry it took so long it sounds like i
bought carlos had a lot to pee in me
or triumph the insult comic dog
i'm eating a snack
facing in this game soon
just up ahead is the village
i'll go and have a look around
i will stay and watch that car
don't want to get any parking tickets
right parking tickets good luck right
you're right
you beat the game you get his uh record
city
uniforms
where are these guys that's pretty cool
did you say something
honey dan
ooh leon i hope you can hear me i'm
ingrid hunnigan i'll be your support on
this mission
loud and clear
somehow i thought you'd be a little
older
so the subject's name's ashley graham
right that's right she's the daughter of
the president so try to behave yourself
okay
whoever this group is they sure picked
the wrong girl to kidnap i'll try to
find some more information on my end as
well
good talk to you later leon out
leon out all right [__]
i'm playing the video game now
oh reappoint yourself with controls yeah
shoot that crow okay
i got him
up
that crow tried to come after me
x reloads
when you're aiming
you played dead space
yeah
you ever do the all-plasma cutter run
uh-uh i've done it all i've done this
handgun all run
just just this hand gun the whole time
crow had a lot of money
[__] him up
rich ass crows
sorry i know this seems jarring but
that's like
i was trying to like slightly raise it
and i don't think you can i think it's
either like zero to a hundred yeah i
really wouldn't use the right analog
stick unless you're aiming like stick to
the left right and then obviously the
quick 180 degree is very crucial in this
game and holding x sprints what was the
180 again just back and forth okay yeah
holding forward and next sprints
okay
and l1 brings out your knife bro oh yeah
which i do i go i'm one of the people
who shoots the legs and then gets the
quick time event yeah just slices them
on the ground to save ammo okay a lot of
it okay
oh wait how do i reload
aim and then press x
i think you're already yeah of course of
course got it
let's see what this thing is
stick him up
i'm robbing you
oh [__]
yeah i played this game last weekend
and uh and yesterday it's still just as
good as ever excuse me first time on ps4
sir
he be stoking the fire
this is like one of four character
models they have for the gennados the
whole game
i was wondering if you might recognize
the girl in this photograph
cabron
sorry to have bothered you i don't speak
spanish
all right freeze all right should i
bring it up right now what happened yes
this guy killed mary the first enemy
during our first he dodges
so like
i just i wanted to try to juke him and
it didn't work out
so if you shoot their legs the right way
you get the kick
contextual event
my people leave me
oh yeah
or no that was just them going to get
you okay
so
[Applause]
i think that's my car right
that they just hit yeah not that truck
though
oh no
okay
there are still others surrounding the
area
get out of there and head toward the
village take whatever measures necessary
to save the subject
your solid vibe to it neutralize them
all oh [__] all right wait
um i need i need more bullets
don't i oh uh so okay just press the
touchpad
you should have a few
i have
15. but i know there's more in here no
there's not it's uh if you go over it
under the stairs it just says like it
remains bones and [__]
what about upstairs oh yeah upstairs
there is the once you turn around
jump out
it just makes me laugh
he's just like
so actually jump yeah does the flip out
of the way
yeah get some distance [__]
do the 180.
oh no there's too many yeah
shoot their legs
so you could knife yeah
yeah
god they scare the [__] out of me
no
oh lord i was making space between them
and you
you can go see what happened to the
dudes if you want i think oh the car
yeah yeah
i've never done this before
i've only gone forward
oh
no
man those guys are super dead
yeah
all right and forward is where you shall
go
onward kennedy onward
and upward upward
you're in the hot seat girl
cut
um
[Laughter]
i'm lost
that's it
tis a dog and a crow
damn it
[Applause]
um
here's a tip anytime you're hitting
those boxes or a clay jars later swing
the white knife twice because sometimes
there's a snake in there oh my god
take
the green hoib it doesn't happen for a
little bit but it's a good habit to get
into take the handgun and a 70 save
because there's no
i'm just going to save over
sure okay
because there's no
saves in this
there's no what there's no save disks
there's no hockey pucks this time oh
yeah which i think really
you can also save at the end of each
chapter remove such a huge part of what
i thought made it so scary was that i
like didn't think i had enough
saves right like it freaks you out wait
kill the crows
got the one on the post is a grenade i
think
i can't believe that doesn't make the
other one run
like i just shot his friend right before
him and he was like i'm gonna finish
whatever i'm doing
it looks like a warning of some sort
i know this guy's got rope through his
eyeballs
seems inviting to me
i would consider that
ominous go up the dog the wolf he's fine
no help him
you'll be thankful you did
watch the ups he has after getting
caught in a bear trap see ya dude
he's a jumper also be careful walking
around why bear traps yeah keep an eye
on the ground really yeah i'm guiding
you too much right now i just
there was one back there i think you're
fine really
what was that over there
nothing okay
sorry i feel like i'm seeing stuff but i
think a lot of that is just the way
like everything looks the same too that
rope connected to the explosives
right into it no
you even called it explosives
like if you wanted to trick me you
shouldn't actually want you to i don't
want you to die so that there's like
rope
no
i didn't know
focus didn't you oh no wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
oh i shot him in the knife him in the
wiener knife is
knife's face
yes i got him
he's
oh my god he's dead
i can't believe there was a stupid bear
trap in there
there's another one i think i hope
you're good
they got you good damn it
right after you told me about the bear
traps somehow it hurt your ribs
that's just the way bear traps are
wait no
which way to the pueblo
it's pueblo
sorry my accent is so poor
damn
i bet i could have gotten that guy to
walk through the bear trap probably damn
there's
i hear them
where are they are they coming from
behind
where are they
i don't like it
are they in that house
now they're near the bridge
who's in the house nobody's in this one
well somebody is but they're not alive
oh i see that
they're really
180 yeah aim shoot
i got it i got it i got it
nice i got it
okay one more oh
i will take that
okay cool
check out the building first that other
dude's not chasing me
well now he is
oh i slid that dude's throat
okay cool
swipe twice in case
[Music]
what's that
when i was young i was so impatient that
i would just shoot the uh boxes with the
tnp that i get later really silly
that's the worst joke oh they get better
they're well slash worse
that looks freshly fresh though yeah
still bleeding
when do i get to heal
you can if you want i've got a couple of
green
herbs we want to combine them
not
not just yet
your full health your max health are now
at the bottom left yellow herbs increase
here
that would heal
we got two now
you're kind of
wasting the red and green's potential if
you
i would wait on using reds for a little
bit until you increase your maxell but i
guess i could just not use any right
like i could take at least one more hit
just use a green one you'd be fine okay
um i like how we're already learning
that i'm gonna have to like
tetris this stuff in here
you get bigger cases too if you have the
money
yeah i have a suitcase
somewhere on my person
where are they
they were up there but they ran away
all right wait um
there are some quick time events in this
game
going
fine right now but
well you told me to wait
yeah i know you're fine you don't need
it they're in the house
ah
there's a window
back up back up back up
do you think i could shoot him through
the window yeah
come on
oh no
we're getting butt stabbed
slash is blowing back hope your spine
feels good
all right
uh is there another one in there no but
there was like three people they're up
on the cliff they're gone okay
[Laughter]
say pueblo again
snake
okay
moving on
sweet
classic resident evil
sequence coming up leon are you old
enough bad question
sorry to hear that i'm sending you a
playing manual hope you find it useful
oh take a look at it thanks
thanks
oh
don't you mean a survival manual oh
right this is nice
telling me all the things that i had to
learn on my own
um
oh
i can kick people
yeah remember the first episode you kept
trying to do that but you always wait
too late no i don't i blocked it out
l1 and r1 switches between weapons and
recovery
keys and treasure okay
okay
let's get some info on ashley thank god
you'll learn to
to hate ashley
um
i do
all right that actually didn't really
help me
oh wait i'm already here got it
i almost went backwards
a classic mary maneuver
all right
so one thing i didn't tell you last time
you got two options for this
you can run around and survive as long
as possible or until they
leave uh with
the handgun
or that guy's so dead remember where the
shotgun was
do you remember where the shotgun was no
if you go into the shotgun house you can
get the shotgun sooner but you will have
to fight
a certain enemy
that's like a music video shot
wait we need like a heavy metal riff
dung
[Music]
oh yeah but once i attack one woman
don't i attack all of them yeah
cause like
you can like get a few things while
you're waiting right now what kind of
things the left
[Music]
there's a box behind you just missed
nope nevermind oh no
oh don't come back this way why because
other guys come from behind you
where am i going
well anywhere you just
survived you can go into that building
get the shotgun but you're going to
fight someone harder do their own thing
i did the wrong thing the other thing we
talked about not doing
yep
should i just run
yeah
[__]
please jump thank you
how's it going sir oh my lord
there's a yellow herb up here can i talk
to you
about our lord and savior
i don't know where anything is
uh
don't
go to the left there will be guys coming
behind you
could go into this building come on wow
i don't want to go i don't want to get
stuck in a building you don't want to
get stuck over this way either guys
how long do i have to last
i don't know exactly how long it is but
i think you have to and you might have
to kill a few people first but no
see ya losers
oh my god i heard that
no no don't um i'm almost dead i know
don't do it yet though okay combine the
green the red but don't use it but
just trust me
i'm gonna die just use okay don't use
that go
go straight and then right
done
i think there's a yellow herb right here
right that's red there's a yellow one
in the box to your left are you sure
r2 okay now get that okay and i'll
combine that one i'm panicking
this is scary i'll come on the yellow
with the breast green okay so now you'll
increase your max health and it all
combine
oh man and i use that it's a roster drug
yeah
cool
hello sir
oh my god
kill some people
shooting the leg
nice
keep in mind that you don't always have
enough time to knife them i always have
enough time to
knife
oh there's a
i don't think i caught it on the roof
where
oh he's about to throw an accident don't
go closer
come on
oh wow that's cool
where is it lunch time for these people
finger
picadillo
caught in the crossfire
cockadoodle don't stop it
that's what you call collateral damage
it's not collateral damage that's bad
aim
oh you know what i actually think jason
is whatever that is
oh my god
you might actually have to trigger the
second group of people to the right
oh yeah they come they're coming
there's there you go nice jeez
so if you went into the building with a
shotgun a chainsaw dude would have come
out but you would have had the shotgun
earlier
[Music]
adios
where's everyone going
bingo
i love that that's like the last thing
that's said before resident evil
four
hey girl one again i have some bad news
i've confirmed the body of an officer
something's happened to the people here
leon you need to get out of there look
for a tower and follow the trail near it
got it
check the rest of the buildings in this
area okay
well i've been turned around easily in
this game so let's just start from
square one like this is where i came
from this building go to that one
okay
i was gonna do it clockwise that's all
oh
let's wait look down in that
oh that's
intestines
something weird sausage links
there's an unpleasant
odor doesn't smell like a refreshing
drink to me
it's [__] gross
go up to that photo of lord sadler
so most of the time once you get later
every time you see that frame there's
usually gold behind it nice
do you just like shoot it off
oh double double box
go through the window the cool way
okay
yeah well i guess that's all i need here
okay bye guys
shotgun building to your right okay
let's do that now while i'm
thinking about shotguns
i'm really sorry dude
it was not my intention
we don't give a [__] about chickens
i feel i feel a little bad about it
if you double tap square he opens the
doors way cooler oh right
don't worry that's just if you want to
barricade this place
i kind of wish i would have done that
but the chainsaw dude would have come if
you came in here
oh right
which i'm sure people are clamoring to
see the chains i do but you'll see
chainsaw people
don't you worry about that
maybe not in this episode
yay
you can knife it oh right that makes
sense
i just thought i'd open the door you
know like a person
don't go up um that window why
because i got other something else for
you go through that one of your right
nope nope nope
yeah it was
shut up
go through this window
now
oh there might be something up here top
of this roof
i'm on a tin
roof
check uh check to the right
nope to the right
i love that huh okay nevermind go up
that way
there's something on the roof up here
spinal
[Music]
let's just spin off
can i just pop pop right off here or
what and there's that one more building
and uh
the tower so i did this one
you can kick in the door anyway
can i get in
here yeah
let's track on amazing oh
ten roof
um
okay
you know what leon kennedy is not a fan
of
ladders
uh yeah there's one more building
that one
how does he get
in front door would be my first try um
that's what they want you to do
i wasn't kidding pardon me ma'am
tricky bastards
[Music]
yeah hot the sharp knife
fake
too late i almost got you
i haven't
had anything bad happen to me because of
a snake yet so
was that too late for a snake kill no
all right i think that's it onward
upward
excelsior
again
i'm really sorry man
it was not my fault look at such an
embarrassing position it died in i know
that's just the way chickens die i feel
like
shoot that one
no i don't feel good about it
sorry get on my way
oh
nice
keep finding stuff
i feel like you just shouldn't leave
all right i'm ready to leave
hit a hard right right here okay
yeah
there's a box in that check but i don't
think there's anything in it it's a fake
out that's a
mean fake [__] you
i told you i know i
didn't seem likely that it would be that
cruel to me there's a ton of stuff in
this one though
god damn it
why they keep psyching me out
fake houses and fake boxes
yes
it's
it's me
how do they have my picture they go on
facebook or something
recently sent information
here's an agent investigating village
don't let this american agent get in
contact with the prisoner
uh prisoners being held in an old house
beyond the farm
they'll be transferred to a secure
location
the prisoner is to stay there until
spurred as notice do not let the
americans know the prisoner we do not
know the american government
we are investigating fear intrusion is
just a coincidence
chief torres mendes
okay
so whoever betores mendez is he's a bad
guy
am i good to proceed yeah he's just
hanging around
yes you can okay
you'll get it eventually
shoot that medallion okay
cool wait
wait
wait so there's dudes in here that i
gotta kill
oh i've
there's only like three or something i
alerted him with my all these chickens
[Music]
i hope you like poop going back into
your butt
oh there's a little save in there
[Music]
you can rocky those are raw
i didn't get a golden egg
last time i played i got a golden egg
here
is that just like random yeah that's
butts
yes
[Music]
verrucka salt what are you not going to
do with the well this time listen back
up i feel like
i feel like we're getting off the wrong
foot here kick that cow yeah
those dead bodies
surprised
wow
wealthy
is that that dog i saved yeah he'll be
back
there there should be another guy
or is there only two
i just don't like being surprised i'd
rather kill them now
there's like one or two
there's one at the top of the barn other
barn
god i am so
rich
oh the top of the barn yep all right
let's do that now
no no no the other one sorry
there was a top to that barn i'm stupid
sir oh
can i sneak up on anyone
ah
yeah you can see but you can knife in
the face this time
i thought the other guy was coming
he was
i get really scared of people
nice good dodge
no regrets no regrets no regrets
man that dude's name is terrible shoot
him
shoot him
if you're ready for you can't shoot
those out here
i'm not ready
die
that one pretty well mm-hmm
better than
the first time you played this part all
right
now
get those gems medallions after you get
all this [__]
spinal tap
it's called spinel
okay
gimme them peters
[Music]
we have a pitas
peters brown peters brown reviews our
video games
this is going really well between you
and me
that's a good dynamic
you think we would establish that by now
in the fourth game
wait no go back
go back go back
you know that yeah it's from home alone
yeah yeah yeah okay uh
look you want me to jump out this window
no i can't look
up to the up
oh
i forgot about the
and behind you
you might not be able to see no you have
to go outside to see this one it's on
the other side okay
yeah thanks i forgot to look for those i
might as well do that while i'm uh yeah
there's one on the windmill over here
and one past the fence okay got it no
problem
no
no problem
yeah
much less trouble than i gave you last
time oh my god again i wish we should
publish that episode as a bonus one
without audio no audio it's basically me
failing for an hour um where am i going
past well i mean don't jump down but
come back this way other way
toward the window
it's straight ahead pretty much past
that fence i see it
shake it shaking i know he's got
some kind of syndrome
[__]
[Music]
keep it together leon
you could go down there if you want i
got it
i got it i got it
you're racing ammo
it's bothering me so much
yeah
can i jump down
let's get this thingy yeah don't [__]
open the well again after you close it
dirty up that pendant
or gold watch whatever it is no
no back up yeah shoot the wooden package
oh right got it just don't check it
again after you shoot the thing right
yes
it doesn't let you guys again for
whatever reason because leon's inept
don't open it dude that's you almost at
the same exact thing
you're out losing out on like three
thousand say that's something to do i
feel like shooting the pendant should do
more damage than
guts sure but this game
it's all about cats got hit
vault over cow
[Music]
on the other side of the second bar you
can i get in here
what
in here yeah but you don't need to yeah
just get the last medallion first where
on the other side of this barn
go through that back door and then turn
around look up
oh
yeah i think that's the last one you can
check your map or triangle if you want
to double check
nope other barn
sneaky sneaky other barn
it's in the front zone
oh my god his aim is like so wiggle
[Music]
oh i barely thought i had that
stop
got it
so you're saying i
deal with this part later
this inner part well i'm saying you can
go save right now if you want first oh i
see
out of my way chickadees
[Music]
the typewriter is like cel-shaded
wait there's a barrel back
some of them
all right where am i going now you're
going past that fence
or
no i think you're going
back here and you need a
help before you go back yeah that way
i'm going this way
are you sure
you haven't done this yet you didn't
like you saved at that time we ended the
last episode no i
you went down there and there was
nothing i got all the medallions
no you didn't you got all these in this
area the rest are in the cemetery
so i don't go in there
only one of those boxes has an item in
there if you feel like getting it but
you can get it later you're going back
that way okay wait go to the right
there's a box no that's the fence
nevermind you're good no it is it is box
go back stop it it's a box to your left
in there
how do i
oh
[Music]
how do i
i can't get in there
is it a roof thing it's a roof thing
isn't it
probably
drop down on that side maybe
yeah
like here yeah
oh
[Music]
what's that
sell it
doesn't have to be the thing
we'll find something
oh no oh no all right get ready to press
the square what am i doing just keep
pressing square but listen yeah no no
don't do that because you're eventually
gonna have to either press l2 and r2 at
the same time or x and square what l2 r2
i there's no good way to explain that
like while it's happening
i should have just let you do it but
they barely give you any time i lost my
you should now you should have the
checkpoint after that door
hopefully
this game's quick time events are stupid
yeah you're good
i don't have a stein it's it's in your
keys and treasures you're fine
oh
it's not it's either going to be l2 and
r2 or x and square
it's just really strong and square at
the same time so unfortunately when you
were saying that
i was looking down at my controller oh
my bad that's okay i just fart
you're not being truthful oh
sprinkles
nice
[Music]
there's a thingy
do i shoot them
cool
can i shoot the rats
bats
yeah i don't think they drop anything
could be wrong
there's only one way to find out
get in my shooting range bat
they're too fast
i'm not good enough at the at shooting
oh sweet gods
screw
it what screw it
i really wanted to shoot a bat
i've seen
kind of tough
oh no shoot that dude shoot that dude
nope dude back
back back back where are you going
to bat no back oh my god
shoot that dude right there he's got
dynamite he'll throw it at you oh that
guy
okay
well i mean
kill him you need to be more specific
did he throw it
no he didn't let even light
oh
it's got a lot of life
there you go
should i collect the diamond should do
the same with that guy he's lightning i
don't know why you kept running i don't
know
keep going behind the cabin oh okay but
watch for bear traps they're everywhere
oh for [__] sake
this place is riddled with traps
what's going on
what should i do
tell me what to do
what's that
noise they can't come out it's a window
you have to jump through
uh
to the bats
i think he's dead
i don't know he let another one shoot
that from there i can shoot dynamite
you're not that ranged but yeah you can
okay
oh
there's someone else thrown at you from
the left i think but watch that trip why
oh my god i don't know what to do
i don't see still throwing them at you
oh the bear trap
we talked about the bear trap
kill that guy okay
nice there you go
i think there's something else in there
okay
don't go toward that farmhouse yet it's
gonna trigger
a cutscene can i go through this window
yeah there's a guy to your right
what do i do
i didn't think he would do that with
dynamite
where not toward the dynamite i didn't
know he threw it who's in his hand i'm
almost dead
use the golden egg no use the regular
eggs
use the eggs get rid of them
oh i only need one
did he die from that in
that incident that's why you shoot the
dynamite or shoot them trip him up but
if i shot him he would have also
exploded with the dynamite well you
gotta shoot him before he walks right up
to your face
you're getting knife butted
mister
that'd be a lesson to you
what was i supposed to do how was i
supposed to avoid that
blur them out
blur no there's no else
oh my goodness
so
okay so out the window again
yeah
[Music]
stuff in that wood chat i think to your
left you want
this one for a bear trap oh right can i
trip them
you can use your knife if you get close
enough and don't step on it it's better
than shooting it
i'll just
oh wait where's the tripwire it blew up
the guy threw a dynamite at it
jerk
[Music]
um
okay so now what
into the house
towards the house
i forgot to look for bear traps
i'm home
this is a safe house
doesn't feel safe
it looks more like a residence 7 house
should i save yeah
could be an episode
yeah how long has it been
about 55 minutes yeah it's good
that's the first episode much farther
than you did last time yesterday
resident knievel is back
for resident evil 4 you guys can look
forward to more episodes uh
coming out soon two-week minimum is our
plan
cool and nothing will stop the plan
[Music]
nothing will go wrong
my aiming's fine
it's okay
it's all right